TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
and welcome back
to Google Cloud Next 2017.
Coming to you live
from San Francisco.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
a developer advocate
and host of the "Dev Show."
DREA ALPHONSO: And I'm Drew
Alfonso, a program manager
on Google for Education and one
of the hosts of the "G Suite
Show."
And we're back for
another full day.
We're excited to
kick it off with you
and give you a peek at what's
going on here in San Francisco.
Today we can expect to learn
more about Google Cloud
products, including new
launches for GCP and G Suite.
Along with that, our top
product and engineering leaders
will share roadmaps and
future product direction.
We'll also check
out some cool demos
and hear from customers about
how Google Cloud is helping
them compete and succeed.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yesterday
over 10,000 people
attended Google Cloud Next
to collaborate and learn.
We heard some great
announcements in the keynote,
such as eBay and HSBC now
running on Google Cloud
Platform, the
general availability
of SAP HANA on Google
Cloud Platform, and a bunch
of machine learning updates,
including the Google Cloud
Video Intelligence API, Cloud
Machine Learning Engine now
in general availability,
Cloud Vision API 1.1 in beta,
and Kaggle joining Google Cloud.
DREA ALPHONSO: A lot of stuff.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
Why don't we go to a clip
with a few more highlights
from day one?
DIANE GREENE: Thank you
so much, and welcome.
This is just an
incredibly exciting event.
Everybody at Google Cloud
is so incredibly proud
of the customers that
we have here today.
SPEAKER 4: 90% of our users
are active on Google Drive.
And in February alone, we
had more than 57,000 hours
of video hangouts.
SPEAKER 5: I'm more
excited by the investments
you guys are making in talent.
And I'm looking
forward to the work
we're going to do with
on exploring some really
interesting problems where we
think that the machines can
help us understand some things
perhaps that the humans find
difficult to understand.
SPEAKER 6: Google,
let me talk to eBay.
GOOGLE: Sure, here's eBay.
SPEAKER 8: Hi, I'm eBay.
I'm the world's price guide.
SPEAKER 9: This is why
the next step for AI
must be democratization.
We at Google Cloud are
making the tools available.
But it's up to you
to put them to use.
SPEAKER 10: Our
customers and partners
will see many ways to
leverage all of Google,
be it Google Maps, Android,
YouTube, or device's ecosystem.
And we'll deliver it
over the most efficient,
high-performing, and secure
core computing resources.
SPEAKER 11: Just get
to the cloud now.
There's no time
to waste anymore.
DREA ALPHONSO: We
all had a chance
to chat with some attendees
about their experience
here at Next.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's take a
look at what they had to say.
DREA ALPHONSO: Let's do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
All right, I know
we're supposed to be
doing attendee interviews.
But I just couldn't pass
up this opportunity.
Here I am with Greg Wilson,
head of developer relations
for Cloud.
Greg, welcome to the show.
GREG WILSON: Thanks,
glad to be here.
I watch your show all the time.
So it's cool to
be on it, finally.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks.
GREG WILSON: You couldn't
find any attendees?
There's like a
million here, man.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We could.
But we spotted you.
GREG WILSON: Oh,
OK, good enough.
Good enough.
All right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So what
we're doing right now
is trying to give everybody
an idea out there what
it feels like to be at
Cloud Next right now.
You've been walking
around the showcase.
How does it feel?
GREG WILSON: Really good.
There's a lot of energy,
a lot of people looking
for new things to learn.
Cloud is hot right now, no
matter who you're using.
Everyone's looking to
get out of managing
their own infrastructure
and trying
to find a provider that can
offer them the services that
do it for them.
So that's what we're
all about in Cloud.
We launched a machine
learning engine this morning
to GA and the Video
Intelligence API.
So I'm already talking to
a lot of developers here
that are already having some
really interesting ideas
for how to use it in
real applications.
And that's why I'm
here, is just to learn
how do people see this
stuff, what are they
thinking about using it for?
And it's fascinating.
It's great to be
a Googler and then
learn about Google products
through the eyes of someone
else, right?
So it's fantastic.
DREA ALPHONSO: So hey, everyone.
I'm with Diana from Xertica.
So Diana taught us a
little bit more about what
you do at Xertica and
exactly who is Xertica.
DIANA: Well, Xertica,
it's a cloud partner
based on [INAUDIBLE] region.
We are the biggest partner.
And we offer G Suite and
G Cloud in Latin region.
DREA ALPHONSO: So
as a partner, we
had our [INAUDIBLE]
summit yesterday.
So talk to us about what
that experience was like.
DIANA: Well, it's
very, very interesting
to have this conversation
with all the VPs at Google
and understanding what
are the important things
they want us to know just
to share with our clients
or with our prospects.
So it's very, very interesting,
this meeting with them.
DREA ALPHONSO: Great day
to kick off the first day.
And today was our
keynote sessions.
We had some of our
speaker sessions as well.
And what were some of the
cool things that stood out
to you in those two things?
DIANA: Actually,
it's the first time
that there is the partner
summit and also a client summit.
So mix them all together
is very interesting for us
because we can understand
now more customer success
stories, things like that.
That was one of the
most interesting things
in the morning for me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: A
lot of attendees
are really excited about all
the innovative stuff happening
with Google Cloud.
But some of them aren't sure
how they can best keep up.
DREA ALPHONSO:
That's a good point.
I'm not sure if you know
this, but last week, Google
announced a collaboration with
Coursera, an online learning
platform.
And I sat down with Louise, who
had important role in making
all that happen.
Hey, everyone.
I'm here with Louise Byrne,
head of training delivery
at Google Cloud.
Last week, Google announced
a new collaboration
with Coursera, an online
learning platform,
which sounds pretty exciting.
So before we get
started, can you
tell us more about
how this addresses
some of the technical
skills gap around the cloud?
LOUISE BYRNE: Yeah, definitely.
We're obviously hugely excited
to have this collaboration
with Coursera.
And one of the things that
we have heard consistently
from our customers, from
partners, from developers,
as well as what recent
research has also shown,
is that one of the biggest
challenges for organizations
and individuals to move and
take advantage of Cloud products
in general is skills gaps.
It has been cited as
the number one concern
that companies have in
moving to the cloud.
We believe that our
investment in training,
and more specifically this
collaboration with Coursera,
will enable us to help
close this skills gap.
By working with Coursera,
what it enables us to do
is provide training in
an on-demand format that
can be consumed by anyone
anywhere in the world
and in a time frame
that works for them.
DREA ALPHONSO: Right.
So with the training-- can you
talk to us a little bit more
about what the training looks
like and what type of courses
are available?
LOUISE BYRNE: Yeah, so
we're really excited, again,
with Coursera because
it's timed with also
the launch of some new training
that we have around big data
and machine learning.
Huge amount of
interest, obviously,
in the whole area
of machine learning,
and so we have that, which is,
just in general, a new course.
We're adding that to
Coursera from the get-go.
And we also have our Systems
Operations Course up there,
a specialization
around SysOps, which
is the course that maps
to the infrastructure
kind of focus of the Google
Cloud Platform products.
And there is many
more courses to come.
So watch this space
over the coming
months for the other courses
that are coming down the line.
DREA ALPHONSO: So
just when we were
talking about with
Coursera and now
with our acquisition
of Quiklabs,
hos do those two
tie in together?
LOUISE BYRNE: Yeah,
I mean, I think
that they tie in really well.
First is, obviously, they
show the commitment and focus
that Google Cloud is
giving to training.
And we are taking this
very, very seriously
in terms of doing whatever we
can to help close this skills
gap and enable people so
that they can take advantage
of the opportunities that
working with Google Cloud
products can bring.
I think also what
it really shows
is our learner-first approach.
What is wonderful about
the Quiklabs platform
is that it provides learners
with real lab environments
on which they can
practice whatever
it is that they have
learned from the courseware,
from the materials.
And they can go in and implement
that in a practice environment,
which is what the labs offer.
Combining that with
the Coursera just
means that you have a
really high quality training
product that can be
consumed anywhere by anyone.
So, yeah, I think it's--
DREA ALPHONSO: So
a bit of learning,
a little bit of application.
LOUISE BYRNE: Exactly.
DREA ALPHONSO: So
where from the courses
and training that
we talked about,
where can we go to learn more?
LOUISE BYRNE: Yes, you
might be surprised to hear
there is a website.
It's a Google Cloud site.
So if you go to
that site, it will
provide all the information
you need around what courses
we have available,
what certifications
are on offer, and
the partnerships
and where you can actually
go and find the training,
whether it is
instructor-led training
or the on-demand training
that we are doing together
with Coursera.
DREA ALPHONSO: Got it.
Now, are there are any
special offerings or discounts
with the new training?
LOUISE BYRNE: Yeah,
I mean, together
with us making
this announcement,
we are super excited
to offer everyone
who's attending Next and
the Next extended event
a voucher for some
Coursera training.
The voucher is valid for the
Google Cloud Fundamentals
course, normally valued at $59.
Anyone with this voucher can
consume that training for free.
So we're really,
really delighted to be
able to announce that
together with Coursera.
DREA ALPHONSO: Awesome.
So a lot of great
trainings, courses,
out there to learn
all about the cloud.
So thanks, Louise,
for joining us.
We're going to kick it back to
the showcase in San Francisco
to see what's happening
at Cloud Next.
LOUISE BYRNE: Thank you.
DREA ALPHONSO: Thanks.
There's lots to learn,
see, and do here.
So we wanted to
make sure everyone
got a glimpse into what
Next is about in addition
to the keynotes and sessions.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's right.
Yesterday we took a tour
of the Cloud showcase,
where you can get really
hands-on with everything
happening here at Next.
DREA ALPHONSO: And of course,
we brought some cameras
along the way.
And this is what we saw.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, we're
now at the Kubernetes
Whack-a-Pod booth with Mandy.
Mandy, how are you?
MANDY WAITE: I'm
pretty good, thank you.
How's it going?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's fantastic.
So just a moment ago, Drea and
I were playing Whack-a-Pod,
and it was a lot of fun.
But could you tell us what
we were doing while we
were whacking those pods?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah,
we're whacking pods.
So these pods are
parts of the components
of an application that are
running within Kubernetes.
We have-- this set
up is a little bit
kind of geared towards the
experience specifically.
But the idea is a pod is a
component of your application.
It can run anywhere [INAUDIBLE]
cluster in Kubernetes.
It can be scheduled anywhere.
It could go down.
If it goes down, it
comes back up again.
It will be managed
effectively by Kubernetes
to make sure that we always
have the right number of pods
at any given time.
In this case, we have
moles instead of pods.
But it's pretty
much the same thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I
think the key thing here
is that as any of them go
down, others are coming up.
And so it's like kind
of a losing battle
to try and bring
these servers down.
Not servers, pods, excuse me.
MANDY WAITE: Not servers, yeah.
We could do the same with
the servers, to be honest.
We can bring the
servers back up as well.
So we could do auto-scaling.
We can have managed
instance groups that manage
the nodes as well as pods.
But pods are very
small, ephemeral units
of your running application.
They're designed to be
ephemeral and replaceable.
So therefore, when
one goes away,
another one will come
back up to replace it,
absolutely identical,
and traffic will
start to be routed to it again.
DREA ALPHONSO: And how would
businesses without Kubernetes--
how would they handle
this without that?
MANDY WAITE: So
basically this is
a kind of different
way of thinking,
a different way of thinking--
we've been working with Google
for the last 10 or so years
through something called Borg.
And basically what
people would do,
they would find they
have lots of containers.
They would have
to manage systems.
And they would have to manage
the container run times
independently.
There are other alternatives to
Kubernetes out there as well.
They can manage
containers for you.
But we think
Kubernetes is probably
the one you should choose.
DREA ALPHONSO: Right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Could we do
it, and maybe you could tell us
what's happening on the screen?
MANDY WAITE: Absolutely, yeah.
Let's go.
DREA ALPHONSO: I'm whacking.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So maybe we'll
just have Drea whack some pods.
MANDY WAITE: OK, so Drea is
currently whacking the pods.
The pods are going down.
They have big hash names.
So you can see each
name is unique.
When they go down, they go gray.
When they're coming back
up again, they go orange.
Then they'll become blue again.
Maybe if you do it
fast enough you'll
be able to take the
entire service down,
but not for very long.
So if you can imagine
somebody is playing havoc
with your systems,
taking your pods down,
Kubernetes will [INAUDIBLE]
for you and make sure
you always have the
right number of pods
running at any given time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's a
pretty great score, Drea.
But when we were doing it
together, it was even better.
DREA ALPHONSO: Oh,
yeah, all right, we did.
I think we hit, like, 1,000.
MANDY WAITE: So yeah,
so that's it really.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is
there anything else
you want to say about
Kubernetes or where
people can get started?
MANDY WAITE: So, yeah, so
you can go to kubernetes.io
to get started.
That's the best place to
start from a documentation
standpoint.
There are lots and lots
of resources out there.
There are great talks
on YouTube, me included.
I've given lots of
talks on Kubernetes.
You can find out more there.
We also have, for anybody who's
actually attending the event,
an expert station here
where you can go and get
questions answered.
So there's a lot of
stuff around Kubernetes
here at the event today.
But plenty of resources online.
You can also tweet us on Twitter
and get your questions answered
there as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
DREA ALPHONSO: Thanks, Mandy.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you.
Cheers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You know,
Drea, I've been really looking
forward to all the machine
learning at Cloud Next
this year.
DREA ALPHONSO: That's
a hot topic here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It is a hot topic.
So it's about time
that we checked it out.
We're here with Kaz.
Kaz would you mind introducing
yourself and telling everybody
out there what you do?
KAZ SATO: Thanks so much.
I'm Kaz.
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
And here we have the so-called
Find Your Candy demonstrations,
where you can tell some
voice command to the tablet
so that the robot can
understand your voice command
and try to find the
best candy for you
and pick it up by
recognizing the image.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
there's a number
of different machine
learning algorithms
going on there, both in
the voice recognition
and understanding not just what
you said, but what it means,
as well as selecting the candy.
Can you walk us
through that flow?
KAZ SATO: Yeah,
so initially, it's
using the Voice Speech API
to recognize your voice.
And then it uses the Natural
Language API to understand
the words inside the sentence.
And then it uses
cloud machine learning
to use the algorithms
called [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] is an algorithm
used to understand
the meaning of each word.
So it understands the
similarity between hot
and spicy or creamy and milky.
And then it tries to use the
[? word ?] to choose the best
candies to pick up.
And finally, it uses the cloud
ML again to recognize the--
to the image recognition
on each object.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's a
lot of machine learning.
KAZ SATO: Yes, tons of it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, shall we try it?
KAZ SATO: Yeah, you can try it.
DREA ALPHONSO: Let's see.
I like mints, oh,
voice recognition.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I see it.
It's finding the
whole sentence there,
it knows what each
of those words is.
I bet it's going to pick
out the noun, right?
KAZ SATO: Yes.
So it understands all
of the parts of speech,
like a noun, an adjective.
And now it's choosing
the candies for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
look, it chooses mints.
DREA ALPHONSO: So talk with us.
I know we're sorting
some candy here.
But talk to us like how this
translates for enterprises
and for businesses.
KAZ SATO: So actually,
this is a miniature version
of the real-world use cases.
And here we have
all the displays
for the cucumber sorter.
Actually, we have a real
cucumber farmer in Japan
who used these same technologies
to build his own cucumber
sorter.
And he spent only $15 to
build his own cucumber
sorter by using Google Cloud
machine learning technology.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool,
DREA ALPHONSO: So
essentially, it
takes the best prototype of
that, and kind of buckets them?
KAZ SATO: Yeah.
So he wanted to build a machine
that can sort out all cucumbers
into nine different classes.
And he took a [INAUDIBLE]
different models
for his cucumbers.
And also build the sorter
by using the Raspberry Pi
and download the TensorFlow,
the machine learning library
from Google to build
his own sorter.
And the point here
is that you don't
have to be a cutting-edge
data scientist or a machine
learning expert to getting
started with the latest
machine learning technology.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Attendees
are having a great time
exploring that area and
getting to know Google
Cloud in a whole new way.
Now, before we jump
to a rundown of what
to expect from
today's keynotes, I
want to make sure that
everyone knows they can't
miss the keynote tomorrow.
DREA ALPHONSO:
They can't miss it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
theme is open source,
and we have an extraordinary
lineup planned.
I'll let Sam and Sarah
tell you about it.
So day three is
kind of unique when
you look at it on the schedule.
What's happening day three
that you're excited about?
SAM RAMJI: It's going to
be a lot of fun, actually.
Sarah is very shy,
as you can tell,
and didn't mention that she's
the past co-chair of OzCon.
So when we started
imagining what
do we want day three to
look like, I thought,
well, we've got two
totally awesome people.
We've got Sarah, past
co-chair, and Kelsey Hightower,
current co-chair of OzCon.
So what if we could
make day three
this open source technology
destination, where
it would just be amazingly
fun to share ideas,
to learn from people at Google
who are building open source
technologies, and just open up
a big conversation on not just
TensorFlow and Kubernetes
and Apache Beam,
but all open source projects
that we're running on
and that we're contributing
to and bring in our experts
to bear, so that we can get
a really live discussion
happening.
SARAH NOVOTNY: And we have
longstanding experts to bear.
We opened with Vint
Cerf talking about how
openness was a fundamental
underpinning of the internet.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Critical, one might say.
SARAH NOVOTNY: One might say.
SAM RAMJI: Yeah, and
of course, Eric Brewer,
who, low-key developed
[INAUDIBLE] and then, low-key,
recently broke it.
So it should be a lot of fun.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
bet there's going
to be some amazing
stories told tomorrow.
DREA ALPHONSO: Most definitely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: As for
today, new products
for Google Cloud Platform and
G Suite will be announced.
And our leading products
and engineering leaders,
including Urs, Prabhaker,
Brian, and Chet
will share roadmaps of
Google Cloud's future product
direction.
You'll also see
exciting product demos
and hear from customers about
how Google Cloud is helping
them compete and succeed.
DREA ALPHONSO: Woo!
Can't wait.
So remember, we'll
be back here tomorrow
about 20 minutes before
the keynote with day two
interview and more
exclusive interviews you
won't want to miss.
We'd love to hear your thoughts
on the future of the cloud
or answer any questions
for you while we're here
with all of our experts.
Our handles are on your screen.
So enjoy the show.
And we'll see you tomorrow.